well hello reject nation it's Greg Alva
here and it's John over here
Humphrey so Justice League we're not
watching anymore trailers oh no no watch
some movie clips that's right even
better than a trailer it's from the
actual natural footage knocking on the
mic around I want to watch some clips
with you because I know for a while now
John has been bitching about how he
wants to cease let me see an actual
scene so I was like fine John we're
watching actual scene we're only
assembling a few of Earth's Mightiest
Heroes there's gonna be a couple of
these videos that we're gonna do we
don't want to just because we can't put
all them in one title so we'll divide
them up but hey patron of the day shout
out today gonna go out some NAT Lyle's
my homie
Matt Lyle got mad II hope that shout-out
is worth your wiles
Commissioner Gordon meets the team oh
good this sounds like a scene brilliant
run hahahaha I wasn't even aware
[Music]
[Music]
parenting minutes okay
movie mattress and they carry the people
away to find out what they know so they
may still be alive 9 the head of STAR
Labs was taken as well I made it
Harrison wells so then there must man is
nearby I plotted all the sightings of
the metropolis Gotham Hill pattern I can
see the lines on the map don't converge
on land Beasley back to Braxton Island
between the two cities Gotham Harbor
these are air vents they only down to
the tunnel to Metropolis project it was
a bangs in this Friday night do you
really think that oh wow they just they
really just vanished
that's rude love it I love it really
amusing and entertaining is watching the
way the rhythm was playing out the way
the scene was playing out interaction I
mean yeah it's just a plot scene it's
not like a character's yeah okay but
here the Batman tune with that know is
that man she was cooking yeah that whole
sequence of shots and like peering up at
him through yeah she can flapping in the
wind like I thought that was really cool
and I like yes a lot
hey I think it feels cheesy it was kind
of corny yeah I'm on board for that
feels like the kind of I feel almost
like I'm watching one of the animated
movies the way a dialogue is and the
sort of life
yeah the tone and the interaction yeah
yeah it feels like that and I'm okay
with that I really am I'm rub being dead
honest here it seems to have this fun
rhythm about it just in a talking team
no I well I know I don't think this is a
bad scene I just didn't find there to be
much of a fun like alright this is a
good time scene I was just like oh yeah
they're figuring out where they gotta go
this channel isn't growing
not because of algorithm and do it slow
alone art of the reef cyborg looks a
hundred percent real it totally made
sense for them to vanish after that line
it also made sense for cyborg ten ten
stars out of five
whatever whatever yeah well watch
another Matt Lyles dude I just want to
say you've been part of our patreon for
so long for months I've been trying to
get you to message me back last month
you actually two months ago you actually
talked to me hey man
we'll get to know each other by 2018 I
cannot wait to finally meet you in
person one of these days bud and he has
a website Matthew Lyle's dot-com where
he does a lot of programming and design
and he works freelance and he is not
asking me to promote this for him but I
looked at his site some great stuff on
there this guy knows his design work for
sure he's a creative director of dude I
love this I love the stuff he has here
so rad web so check it out Matthew Lyles
calm at sea it's like a fancy
this isn't something like pay five bucks
and get your own domain name type of
deal like we had for a month some
Matthew Lyles keep up the sexy styles my
friend anyway I subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
follow us on social media we're gonna
watch another one